[Music]
where we start with couples
many of whom have experienced being
alone most of their lives traumatized or
not where we start is we help couples
see the the dance they're caught in love
is a dance we help couples see the dance
they're caught in
we help couples see the negative
patterns the most popular one of all is
i become aware of the disconnection
between the two of us
i get worried about it it makes me
anxious and i don't feel safe enough to
turn and really share my vulnerability
so i demand i blame
i tell you where are you what i'm really
saying is where are you where are you i
can't find you and that alarms me but
what i say is things like you don't talk
to me enough or you know you never tell
me how you feel
or you know if you're a man you'll say
you never tell me you want to make love
you don't ever show me you want me
what's wrong with you i said we turn to
our partner we say what's wrong with you
so we help couples see how they scare
the hell out of each other
and
create
even more insecurity
and stop each other from being able to
be vulnerable and risk when they start
to see that it's the pattern that's the
problem the dancers problem
and the fact they they don't know how to
do a more positive dance
they start to blame the dance rather
than each other and they start to be
able to say hey we're stuck in that
thing we're stuck in that thing we do
where i shut down and shut you out and
you must be getting alarm right now and
the other person says yes i'm starting
to freak out and they say oh let's not
do that let's try and help each other
feel a bit more safe so we create that
platform first but then you have to
start where people are
and sometimes with a hold me tight
conversation with somebody who's been
very traumatized
and has all the reasons in the world
not to trust another human being
with the softness of their heart
all the good reasons in the world
you have to start there
i've worked with lots of traumatized
folks and you have to start with
somebody saying
i understand now the patterns and how
we've been caught in this dance
i understand that you aren't always
trying to hurt me
or have me prove myself to you or prove
me wrong
but i want to tell you
the idea of really opening up to you
and showing you who i am
just feels impossible i don't know how
to do it it's impossible i don't think i
can do it so you start where people are
you don't get people to do it in spite
of how they feel
you get them to trust their feelings my
experience is someone will say that
and i will say could you turn and tell
your partner please
i don't think i can do it
i don't think i can risk letting you
really see me
i'm so sure that you won't want me
or that you'll find some way to hurt me
then i don't know what would happen i
don't think i could tolerate it i don't
think i can do it
could you turn and tell her what i do is
i hold the person
and i help them
speak their emotions
and say their emotions clearly
and i hold them in that i support them
in there so guy turns and tells his wife
and his wife says
and this is the amazing thing about
bonding
this is who we are
we are empathic creatures that empathy
is blocked by all kinds of other things
but we are empathic creatures my
experiences the partner will say
i never knew that
i just felt that you didn't want to
share with me
i never knew it was so hard
i never knew that it was scary for you i
never understood that
i can't believe
i understand i understand that
now you've helped me understand
how scary that is
i can't believe
that you're even here telling me this
and i love you for taking that risk
thank you for taking that risk
and then the door opens wider
and then i say
usually i say because we always have
this catastrophe in our head when we're
afraid we create catastrophes in our
head to try and prepare for them right
so i say what is going to happen if you
really show her who you are
and you show her how scared you are to
really open up and show your
vulnerability what is going to happen
and he says
she'll tell me what i've always known
she'll tell me that i'm weak
there's something wrong with me
and the reason that i've been alone all
my life is because there was something
wrong with me and the reason i was so
hurt when i was little was because i
wasn't a good enough kid
or a special enough kid
i didn't do it right
one lady broke my heart she said i was
so careful when i asked my mother for
attention i was so so careful i'd plan
it and plan it in the dark for hours
no matter how i did it it never worked
it never worked she was always angry at
me
so i said to myself it's me it must be
me
there's something wrong with me
i'm just not lovable
and she weeps
when she does that her partner reaches
for her naturally her partner reaches
for her and says
this vulnerability
when you really help people move into it
with safety evokes caring and compassion
it just does so then the partner moves
in and supports and gradually gradually
the other person's able to open up it's
not something that you do once
you know it's not something that you can
do mechanically
you have to be involved in it and for
some of us
if we've been desperately hurt when we
were nidal
and we learned that that kind of
openness was desperately dangerous
it's like jumping off a cliff and you
have to respect that you have to respect
emotions are in no way illogical
that's one of the big mistakes we've
made in psychology they're in no way
logical they have their own logic
they're a supreme
information processing system
that it wires us to see the world in a
particular way to move in a particular
way and we haven't taught people how to
understand them how to listen to them
and how they make sense they always make
sense
if someone's terrified of that kind of
openness
it's because they have very good reasons
to be
and often they haven't told their
partner
they haven't told their partner anything
about it so their partner has no idea
the partner says you just don't want to
be close to me
you just don't want me
no i do desperately want you i'm just
terrified
to let you see me
in psychology we're very good at looking
at the behavior and the problem
and
sometimes i feel like we're not so good
at what we are supposed to be the
experts in which is looking underneath
the behavior and the problem and seeing
the emotional realities that push that
problem forward and keep people stuck in
that problem
you